on va vous retrouver dans un instant
mais un tapis je le disais dans les
titres l'université d'été du mouvement
des radicaux de gauche s'est réuni ce
week-end près de saint tropez
il s'agit pour le émerger de définir une
stratégie à l'aube d'une année
présidentielle depuis l'adhésion de
bernard tapie ou émerger les rangs des
militants c'est incontestable ont
considérablement grossi roland sicard
eric de la nuit du premier coup
l'évidence s'impose les radicaux ont
bien changé avant c'était le parti du
cassoulet et des digestions difficiles
maintenant c'est le mouvement des
matches de foot et des exercices
nautique
bernard tapie est passée par là bernard
bosc fait partie de cette nouvelle
génération il a pris sa carte ont émergé
il y à un peu plus d'un an il ne faisait
plus confiance au parti socialiste
déchiré par les guerres de couret et ce
ne sont pas les affaires dans lesquelles
le nom de bernard tapie a été cité qui
le feront changer d'être bernard tapie
quand même depuis dans les affaires
depuis un certain temps et comme par
hasard ça c'est pas ça s'est déroulé
l'année dernière quand on savait que
bernard tapie avait donc une volonté
politique de figure est donc au premier
plan donc pour moi c'est des attaques
politiques
à l'opposé gérard bateau est un ancien
du émerger il a pris sa carte il ya un
peu plus de vingt ans il a connu robert
fabre michel crépeau françois doubin et
saynètes l'arrivée de bernard tapie lui
pose problème
personnellement
je suis extrêmement réservé mais je ne
je ne représente l'idée dominante est la
tendance 2011 de nrg qui au temps qu'il
me semblait très très tapis et de fait
les chiffres sont là le nombre de
militants du émerger un plus que doublé
depuis l'arrivée de bernard tapie lui
reste même chez les anciens beaucoup
applaudissent je n'ai aucun état d'âme
quant à l'arrivée de bernard tapie au
contraire je crois que ça a été une
bonne chose dans la mesure où le
mouvement qui avait des idées avaient
besoin de quelqu'un qui les forcent
fortement est toute la question est là
jusqu'où porter ces idées beaucoup
poussent bernard tapie à se présenter à
l'elysée pensante l'une campagne
présidentielle est indispensable car se
faire vraiment entendre bernard tapie
n'a pas encore répondu
alors les militants du émergent réfute
et attendre